اشرح عندما قمت بتصوير هذا الفيديو
وماذا نشاهده نحن نرى ما
حدث هنا
لذلك أخذنا هذا الفيديو بعد دقائق من
مغادرة آخر طائرة أمريكية وفي
تلك المرحلة كان لديك نوع من
قناع طالبان حول جوانب  المطار
وبعد ذلك عندما رأوا أنه لم يكن
هناك المزيد من الطائرات ، أغاروا قليلاً
ثم دخلوا بشكل جماعي ، وأه كما تعلمون
كنا كما
أعتقد ، فإن الطريقة الأولى التي تمكنا من خلالها التوجه
نحو البوابة التي كنت تعرفها
حتى  قبل دقائق قليلة كان يحرسها
الأمريكيون ودخلوا أه كانوا قادرين على
فحص الهناجر أه المدرج
بالطبع أه وكانوا يقومون بعملية
مسح كاملة لما كانوا
قادرين عليه الآن بشكل
أساسي ، أعني الآن أن المطار على وجه الخصوص
في أيديهم بالكامل أه أنت تعلم أنني أعني
أنهم يأخذون المنطقة بأكملها
الآن هذه حظيرة للطائرات ،
هذا هو فهمك أن هذا كان
حظيرة كانت موجودة حتى وقت قصير من
قبل القوات الأمريكية التي
تبدو وكأنها شينوك تبدو وكأنها  شينوك
طائرات الهليكوبتر  المروحية التي كانت تستخدم لنقل
موظفي السفارة وآخرين
تمامًا ، نعم ، وأعتقد أن هؤلاء تم
تفكيكهم جزئيًا ، ولكن كان لديك
أيضًا مروحيات أخرى أيضًا ،
وكان هناك أيضًا حالة من الغموض رأيناها
في المعسكر أيضًا ، على
الرغم من أنني أعتقد أنهم  ربما تم
تعطيل الكثير من الأشياء ،
لذا تعتقد أن المروحية قد
تم تعطيلها ،
أعني أنك تعلم أنني لست خبيرًا لأكون
واضحًا ، لذلك لا أريد التظاهر بمعرفة
ما لا أعرفه  ولكن يبدو
أنه تم تفكيكه ، لذا لم يتم تركه
بطريقة ليتم تجميعه جيدًا وهذا
ليس بالأمر السهل ، أعني أنه
ليس مجرد مسألة إمساك
مفك براغي وتجميعه معًا من
الواضح أنه يحتاج  بعض المهارة
والمعرفة وتدريب القوة
بالزي الذي
يبدو عليه جنود طالبان أو الذي
يرتديه جنود طالبان أقصد أن هؤلاء
يشبهون الزي الأمريكي ، هل تعرف من أين
أتوا ،
أعني بالتأكيد أنهم قدمنا لهم ، كما تع
مون؟  لن اقول لك  من أين
أتوا بالضبط ولكن أعني أن لديهم أيضًا
نظارات للرؤية الليلية كما تعلمون أنها
بنادق وأربعة وستة وستين
وكل هؤلاء تم توفيرهم من قبل الولايات
المتحدة والزي الرسمي بالطبع متماثلون